- [Instructor] We're told
that Lauren uses a blend
of dark roast beans and light roast beans
to make coffee at her cafe.
She needs 80 kilograms of beans
in total for her next order.
Dark roast beans cost $3 per kilogram,
light roast beans cost $2 per kilogram,
and she wants to spend $220 in total.
And they tell us here's a graph
that shows a system of
equations for this scenario
where x is the number of kilograms
of dark roast beans she buys
and y is the number of kilograms
of light roast beans she buys.
All right, let me scroll down
so we can take a look at this.
And so sure enough, so this blue line,
and I'll write it out in blue,
this x is the number of
kilograms of dark roast beans,
y is the number of kilograms
of light roast beans,
and she wants to buy a
total of 80 kilograms.
That's what they told us up here.
We can go back to look at that.
She needs, I'll underline this in blue.
She needs 80 kilograms of beans.
So that constraint that
the sum of the kilograms
of dark and light is equal to 80,
that's represented by this equation.
And if we were to graph it,
that is this blue line right over here.
And then this other constraint, three x,
well, the dark roast beans
cost $3 per kilogram,
so three x is how much
she spends on dark roast.
Two y is how much she
spends on light roast
'cause it's $2 per kilogram.
And 220 is the amount
that she spends in total.
And they tell us that up here.
Dark roast beans cost $3 per kilogram,
light roast beans cost $2 per kilogram,
and she wants to spend $220.
So this equation is
another way of expressing
what I just underlined up here in green.
And the green line shows all
of the x y combinations that
would match these constraints.
And so now let's do something interesting.
They've labeled some points
here, point C, D, F, and E.
And we're gonna think about what do each
of these points represent?
So for example, this point
C that is on the green line,
but it sits above the blue line,
what does this tell us?
What does this point C represent?
Pause this video and think about it.
Well, if we're on the green line,
that means that the amount
that she spends on dark roast
plus the amount that she spends
on light roast is adding up
to exactly $220.
So she's definitely spending $220 at C,
but how many total kilograms is she using?
Well, the fact that for this given x,
we're sitting above the line,
that means that she's not
using exactly 80 kilograms.
And we can see that over here.
She's using, looks like
10 kilograms of dark,
and it looks like something
like 95 kilograms of light.
If you were to add those
two points together,
it looks like she's using
something closer to 105 kilograms.
So point C is a situation
where she is spending exactly $220,
but she's using more than 80 kilograms
'cause it's not meeting
this second constraint.
It's sitting above that line.
Now let's think about point D.
What does that represent?
Pause the video and
try to figure that out.
Well, because we sit on the blue line,
that means that we are
meeting this constraint
that the kilograms of
dark and light combined
is equal to 80 kilograms.
So she's using exactly 80 kilograms here,
but what about her spending?
Well, because this point
lies below the green line,
that tells us that we are spending
less than $220.
And we could even try it out.
Three times 20 plus two times 60 is what?
60 plus 120 is $180.
And so this is a point where
we're meeting this constraint,
but we're not meeting this constraint.
We're underspending right over here.
Now, what about point F?
Well, point F sits below
both of these lines.
So pause your video and
think about what that means.
Well, if we're sitting
below both of these lines,
that means that neither
are we spending $220,
nor are we using 80 kilograms.
And you can see that if you
actually look at the numbers.
You don't have to do this,
but this is just to make
you feel good about it.
It looks like she is
using 30 kilograms of dark
and 30 kilograms of light,
so in total she is using,
so this is a situation
where she's using 60
kilograms in total, not 80.
And so that's why we're not
sitting on this blue line.
And if you look at how
much she's spending,
she has 30 kilograms of each,
so three times 30 plus two times 30,
that's going to be 90 plus 60.
That's also less than 220,
and so that's why we see this
point is below these lines.
And then last but not least,
what does point E represent?
Well, point E sits on both of these lines,
so that means that it meets
both of these constraints.
This is a situation where
she is spending exactly $220,
and the total number of
kilograms she's using
of dark and light is exactly 80.
And so if we wanted to
say, hey, what combination
of dark and light would she need
in order to meet both
constraints, E represents that,
the intersection of these two lines.